[Musique]
oui
ah ah
au lacanau de tavernost est à noter
juillet le ps n'aime pas mais yamada
manière que j'ai fait j'ai tout gâché sa
totale des questions je crois vous
n'avez pas tout compris et c'est que
j'ai dit - non je répète intéresse je
suis votre nouvelle professeur
d'espagnol
je m'appelle ana maria autrement dit
pepy par sipa pitaya venez me connaît
l'epitech l'annoncé le diminutif
desrochers fina parce qu'un espagne nous
on adore l'immunité
j'ai la présenter les micros marche pas
très bien bernard vous êtes nombreuses à
une grande classe aujourd'hui je suis
très contente
alors je disais qu'est un espagne en
attendant les diminutifs à leurs aînés
sont logiques puis le comprend par
exemple
maria isabel si on fait la contraction
ça fait mary bale - la bouche et
mâchonnent mme enos il y en a en
revanche qui comprend rien du tout et
par exemple sur la piste qu'a fait
jusqu'à ça fait pipi ma les diminutifs
il est même plus longue que le prénom ou
alors si si je vous jure m il ya
d'autres pays aussi oui j'utilise un
diminutif par exemple un angleterre et
billy vous savez c'est quel prénom sa
williams moins biaisée et de you speak
english speaking to your heart and just
do you et car nous les espagnols on
prolonge le h et on le filme au seuil et
moi au début quand je suis arrivé en
train si je croyais que la chiche par le
mannequin s'était depuis les poudriers
wen
les premiers cours aujourd'hui qu'on va
faire c'est sûr la famille la familia la
famille lien est moins importante mais
ma femme il est à moi bombe à l espagnol
mais sinon les normands allaient et rien
à voir avec les films de pedro almodovar
tous à manama et les perdu ma mère ma
maman elle s'appelle maria et son père
est là oui c'est alberto et non
j'exagère mais roberto est un revers
tout comme il a fait du polar avec la
grand-mère la voix lapin avec des mots
comme le tableau ya la cantinière comme
j'écris irola la boutin ur la drac ou
dernières attendent mais peut-on
craindre des mésanges tamponnaise et oui
ça il faut paraît tenir et c'est les
gros mots nous ne le leur moi non je
suis votre nouvelle professeur
d'espagnol
je suis espagnol enfin j'ai bien de
catalunya olaria sait plus trop s'il est
espagnol
mais ma famille vient de la rioja y
avait ils connaissent la région de la
rioja
là bas on fait du binôme du 20 20 20 sur
20 et et au début quand je suis arrivé
ici à paris j'ai parlé pas très bien
français
en fait je disais ben parvint m'acheter
un espagnol les baies élevé du prononce
pareil alors on est vu avec les élèves
je disais bits au lieu de vie tu allais
quand les petites [__] mais a montré la
[__] à ya rien d enceintes aux essais
comme le sont sûrs qu'elles n'existaient
pas un espagnol de son ulm et j'ai dû
apprendre à prononcer le son hub et pour
ça j'ai une méthode très efficace mais
je vais vous la boe parce que vous êtes
mais c'est pas tes gosses vous mettez la
bouche en cours depuis tom au cul des
poules
c'est l'excellent en sus et vous
prononcez y va on va le faire tous en
sus u avait la reine
oui viennent vous êtes bon françaises et
russes du mouillé moi non commentée
comme on dit à peine nommé rouge temps
et j'aime est appelé sous sa marque
parce que c'est plus espagnol est vous
savez on donne les prénoms comme ça dans
mes coups alors j'aime est appelée
soussana et on va répéter tous un simple
média mot sauce anna may hamm haussmann
- biais aînés dont on se connaît bien
maintenant
alors match et utoya c'est ça vous va
mais non isabelle je te dit tout mais
non je te dis tu non j'étais tutoie
tenez je te dis pas je te tutoie et toi
tu me tues moi tu me dis toi tu m'as dit
ou tu veux rien dire
elle va me tuer savez les moineaux et
tant pis si aulas on t'appelle soussana
d'ailleurs soussana vous avez vu on dit
mais l'espagnol zara cheveu sur la
langue mais pas tout le temps parce
qu'on a dit shoshana on à paris ça n'est
pas tellement d'effet la répète
par exemple au mexique mais ils vont pas
là n'est pas alors que nous sommes
espagne 6 enfin ça dépend pas tout le
temps il ya des fois ci en attendant il
ya par exemple ils ont par la jeune
génération qui fait tout dans la tête a
avec les et les voyelles et imaginons
s'appelle aucune avancée n'a ainsi
j'avais pas compris et je suis coincée
du cul qui est particulier la polio a
non c'est pas les accuser le coup mais
pour nous les espagnols des portugais
c'est la même chose tu prenais même en
été mais le pronom sessions différentes
par exemple est tout fait un bond gilles
grasset c'est comme si vous vous combien
tu me c'est comme ça et comme son frère
mais la coach du pana espagnol ici on
dit constipé pour arrimer après année il
sait capter constipé c'est pas le mec
est bouché sous sa marque est et la
corse
l'espagnol s'est quand même une langue
qui chantait ses mains et b oh que c'est
qu'est ce qu'on va faire payer
on va apprendre des chansons khan younès
famille mégane pas à plus ces méthodes
génial pas apprenez langue étrangère moi
par exemple j'ai appris l'anglais avec
mac os jackson allait me demande ma
musique
vous connaissez la chanson assez léger
c'est un bon moment parce que je suis
moins bien marché que tout sans jamais
assez les cff
qu'est ce que ça veut dire les paroles
rien du tout mais c'est rigolo main au
hameau chanel flammes et claro et
l'amérique se répartissent parvient à
leur prochain dès le flamenco
tu rajoutes des a et des eaux à toutes
les cibles à atteindre qui comprend plus
rien mr c'est beau et est aussi tu
aspires les est ce bien la gérer
et mme bernard il a bien joué a dit aux
[Musique]
commerçants
ah ah
[Musique]
kerviel
c'est la fin de la classe et tout ça va
mieux c'est encore plus intéressant et
je vais récupérer l'herbe à nicot et je
vous dis à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
pas de big n
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]